[Music]
Hello everybody welcome
thank you for the sponsors thank you for
inviting me uh here to Tel Aviv I love
it thank you for the wonderful weather
that you scheduled for me it's been
fantastic I've been swimming yesterday
in the ocean and it was nice
never done that in December before
okay this is a a keynote it's the first
one I talk of the day so it's supposed
to be light and fluffy and very pleasant
so I just want to say thank you to
everybody I love python so much data is
good okay fluffy part is over are you
ready for a technical talk
okay
answer the questions for me what do we
want
when do we want to or how do we want
them
and when do we want them all right you
shall have them okay so uh most of the
talks that I saw scheduled today are
about all the wonderful things you can
do with the stack with the uh the
technology that is given to you how can
you put it together and do interesting
things and I look forward to all of
those talks this is on the other side of
that this is looking at the technology
that you're building on top of the stuff
that you should take for granted what's
on the inside uh in the core
for the most part as you're working you
don't have a need to think about it but
I'd like you to know about some of the
tech that's behind it and uh
being a group of nerds and Geeks as I
heard you announced a few minutes ago I
think you might be interested in some of
those uh internals okay so the functions
I want to highlight here are factorial
in the math module combinations
permutations in numpy the sum function
and in math uh fsum several functions in
the statistics module and the hypotenuse
function these are used a lot in the
core underneath the stack even if you
don't use these functions uh every day
we'll talk about the relevance later the
main group of core developers who work
on this is myself Stephen diprano mostly
in the statistics module Tim Peters is
involved in everything that's important
anytime I'm questioning my mathematics
and need to go another dimension out I
go to Tim uh sir he and what to call out
has just done magnificent work and he is
continuing to do this under very hostile
circumstances he is in eastern Ukraine
the power goes off he works on his
laptop coding all day power comes back
on and he checks in a code so some of
what you're going to see is what sir he
has accomplished under a fairly dire
circumstances and then there's Mark
Dickinson uh so uh this is the group of
people who work on the mathematical
things in Python
so things that have happened news
factorial what happened to it
I'm pointing at the answer
it's not intended to be a hard question
what happened to factorial it got fast
okay so uh did the factorial 101 uh just
for the straight uh product and 2.8 uh
microseconds now we run uh the factorial
in the math module and it's now measured
in nanoseconds five times faster
combinations got fast
combinations of 52 things taking uh 31
at a time
just using regular factorial which we
just showed had gotten fast and that
takes uh 578 nanoseconds but now he used
the one in the math module 31
nanoseconds 15 times faster
you're supposed to be stunned by all
this stuff oh
and what happened to summation
I'm pointing at the answer as I always
do
it became accurate so I've got uh uh
0.1 10 times and I add them up with
regular sum
does that agree with your intuition of
what 1 10 times 10 is
no it's a problem it's wrong
so you go into numpy and try the same
thing and something wonderful about the
answer what's better about this answer
it's correct okay and then in the math
module there is uh fsum I'll show you
how all of these things are possible and
the technology behind it and what
happened to the hypot function
there's two answers this is a harder
question
it became accurate and what else
and multi-dimensional so we have uh
three numbers here and compute the
hypotenuse you do you do know how to
compute the hypotenuse of a triangle
using the Pythagorean theorem
you're
do you think this would this example
would work for you
you think you could do that without math
hypot
it will overflow immediately as soon as
you square it but not with uh not here
okay uh that pretty much wraps it up uh
any questions from the audience
yes sir
the question was this kind of speed and
accuracy seems impossible can you tell
us how we made it possible well I'm glad
you asked Mickey
he's my friend a long-term friend and a
plant I appreciate that all right so
we'll start with factorials how to
compute them like a boss well the
bending ideas first one is a left shift
is cheaper than multiplying by two
if you pull out the evens uh when you
multiply a factorial but let is left
with odd factorials and you can divide
the evens get the odds again and do this
recursively the consecutive odd
factorials built on top of each other so
you use dynamic programming technique
fancy technology to reuse the previous
technology uh previously computed odds
so here is 19 factorial then the
old-fashioned way
step one pull out the even terms so
here's a run of odds and here is a run
of events
we'll leave the odds alone and the evens
will divide them by two
so uh this run of events turns into
another factorial it's just nine
factorial we divided by two here here
here here here here here here here here
here here
for a total of nine times what is the
easiest way to put all those twos back
in I'm pointing at the answers I always
do
left shift by uh uh nine so we've
simplified the problem and are now
working with smaller numbers factorials
get really large really quickly and as
they get large they get really slow and
so once again we're still getting the
same answer but I've got another
factorial in it we can use the same idea
again what do we do collect out the even
terms so this group here's the odd
sequence here's the even sequence divide
those by two there's four of them this
time add four more on to here the left
shift is 13 and this turns into a four
factorial lather whence repeat
and we work our way down to
the factorial is computed this way with
the sequence of our odds so here's a one
odd run a little bit larger odd run a
little bit larger our odd run and then
uh 16 play shift at the end cutting the
work uh by more than half
here's uh how it's done in pure python
of course it's implemented in C under
the hood and the little function gives
the right answer as does the math
factorial here the important thing is
it's super fast and this is the kind of
tech that is underneath the hood almost
everything that you think has an obvious
answer somebody's put a lot of thought
into this read research paper scanned
online put deep thought into how to make
this stuff go fast and so that's at the
basis of uh your stack there were a
number of ideas in here I started with
factorial not because it was super
interesting but because it has ideas
we're going to build on later
what can you do with factorials use them
to uh compute combinations so
combinations come up a lot when we're
doing a probability analysis
so I want to do the combinations of 52
things taken 31 at a time
and the mathcom function gives you the
right answer that's not the interesting
part it's an important part but it's not
the interesting part so how do they
teach it to us in school
the traditional approach the traditional
approach is you take other factorials of
n K and N minus K and this is a baseline
function and call it and it gives the
same answer as our comp which is a very
reassuring
here's the problem though
when you have abstractions like this it
hides behind the abstraction how much
work is going on in this case even with
relatively small numbers like 52 and 31
the intermediate values are really large
for instance the factorial of n here is
this highlighted number
and even for your modern electronical
computer
this is a big number you do enough of
these it starts to eat memory it starts
to slow down really fast and you start
to get into larger factorials
combinations of 500 things taken 200 at
a time these numbers get really large
and actually consume a a fairly big
chunk of a memory so what you're
supposed to see from this is the numbers
are big what is the problem with the
numbers
they're big and big means slow
so how can you tame uh large values what
technique is the best big number tamer
in the world
logarithms
oh would you like to know a trivial fact
about uh logarithms that make you fun at
parties
the word logarithm is an anagram for
algorithm
okay so I can use logarithms and built
into the math module is the L gamma
function gamma being a a continuous
version of factorial offset by one and
so I can just call the math module to
compute the Gammas and amazingly it
gives me uh the right answer now this
should unsettle you a little bit because
combinations is a integer problem what
domain are we working in with things
like L gamma
floats
and you know how floats are the world
starts to fall apart
you remember what chronicer taught us
God created the integers
what's the rest of the quote
all the rest is the work of man we're
responsible for this and all the
atrocities that ensue and so this will
fall apart at some point I had to put a
round in here to get this back out of uh
floats and into the integer domain and
it's some sufficiently large value of n
not very large at all this falls apart
but it is a big improvement over these
giant factorials and this uh does not
slow down and will actually handle
really large inputs and uh even if it's
off a little bit for really large
numbers it's incredibly fast this is a
huge Improvement do you agree
ah but there's a problem
what's inside this uh function is an
approximation from uh lenses
and that formula has a continued
fraction about uh 13 layers deep and so
it takes some time to compute do you
have time to waste sir
no you do not you must you're thinking
there must be a better way some person
knew what to say whenever I pound on the
table what are you supposed to say
there must be a better way so in fact
there is a better way we can pre-compute
these and so I can pre-compute log
factorials very easy to do uh
dictionary comprehensions are rather
beautiful don't you think
okay so that just says build me up a a
table up to 54 of the all of the log
factorials and so our function above
just simplifies to a lookup this is
several times faster and uh uh can we
can tweak this table a little bit to
make it uh more accurate than the L
gamma approach
and so we can go up to a little bit
higher to about uh and equal 53.
[Music]
it's not exciting what would be exciting
instead use what
group Theory all right this is so beyond
uh uh cool we get homomorphisms we get
group Theory we get modular arithmetic
you're excited about all these things
like I am right
there's a reason I came here you all
will enjoy this there are other groups
of people who might not be as interested
in this as I am but I know that you're
locked into this so
in C code we have a 64-bit uh uh
integers available to us where did they
just go
right here and when you add in uh you
went 64
if your additions overflow they
automatically wrap around and same thing
for multiplication they automatically
wrap around which means that all of your
operations are automatically modulo 2 to
the 64. this is fantastic it's given to
us for free guaranteed by the language C
which is just passing through uh
uh capabilities in the underlying
Hardware why does that matter to us
modular arithmetic always forms a what
a group
of elements that are co-prime to the
modulus so anything uh time you have
modular multiplication
if you any element that's co-prime to
the modulus forms a group
all odd numbers are co-prime to a power
of two so every odd number below 2 to 64
is an element of the group
why do we care because groups have
several interesting properties they're
they have uh identity element they're
closed they're associative and the most
important for us is they have a
multiplicative inverse this is fantastic
it means that you can look up a number
uh in this group and find right away
through a simple lookup what its inverse
is and then division becomes as fast as
multiplication and sir did you have time
to spare you did not so how do you want
your divisions long and slow or fast
with a single look up
excellent choice my friend that's what I
would do as well
so
that's still a lot of multiplicative
inverses to compute but we don't need
them all all we need is the ones for uh
the factorials so we can build a table
of the factorials in this group the
problem is the factorials get really
large
to the Fantastic property known as group
homomorphisms everything that we would
want to do in a factorial has a mirror
image in the much smaller set of uh the
64-bit integers so here's the Maths for
it this is the kind of thing I wouldn't
show at any other uh conference we can
look up an odd factorial
we can look up its inverse and look up
the inverse of the N minus K which looks
very much like the formulas we had done
before but this time integer arithmetic
and that gives us a odd result mod 264.
to make all of our uh
factorials odd what we have to do is
remove all the even components shift off
the right bits and we can track those in
a separate table how many times do you
have to shift a number uh n factorial in
order to make it an odd number so just
clip off all of the zeros until you get
a one on the right
and then finally to put it back together
take the odd result and shift it this
will work as long as this result
is under 2 to the 64. here's the
fascinating thing it always works
when this is under 264 even if the
factorials are much much larger than uh
to the 64. would you see this your mind
will go just well mine did so the
pre-computation is really easily done
not very uh exciting we compute a
factorial
compute the shift on it
uh shifted over leaving an odd number
and then use uh this is really something
you all should know about there's a
three argument form of pal in built-ins
and it can raise to a power to a given
modulo and if you put in a negative one
it computes an inverse for you most
people don't know that that is there It
Is Magical it uses the extended
euclidean uh algorithm uh it's one of
those hidden Jewels inside python that
allows you to implement RSA arithmetic
uh encryption in Python in one line of
code
which I think is just mind-blowing so
that's the pre-computation step this
coat looks amazingly like what we had
before we look up an odd factorial
uh and subtract out the K and the N
minus K this part over here when done in
C we get for free so we don't actually
have to do a division there or modulo it
happens automatically when you multiply
it and this is just the uh an integer
minus two other integers and a simple
left shift so we run this and proves
that it works it got the same answer as
everything else
here's the cool part
I think it's remarkable that these huge
factorials are encoded in 64-bit numbers
and I'm in front of a group where I get
to use this word and not feel like a
nerd there's a homomorphism going on
here a really cool one
so here's uh in a our example with the
end of 52 here's its factorial rather
large number uh here's the K and the N
minus k
but if you look in the tables the
numbers uh are much much smaller because
they are all mod 2 to the 64. so all of
the knowledge of what's going on here is
encoded in these much smaller numbers so
we've taken a big problem and reduced it
to a much much smaller uh problem and
the total amount of work for this uh
function is
what is that six lookups
two integer multiplies and two subtracts
and one uh one shift which as you saw on
the previous page when we timed it is
measured in only a few nanoseconds
making its one uh the compute
computation of combination one of the
fastest things in Python it went from
that's the one that sped up by about a
factor of 15.
what about uh larger values this will
work up to about n equals 67. I can go
up to n at uh 127 for smaller values of
K for larger ones we use this recurrence
relation this was a contribution by uh
survey and this takes the big problem
Smit splits it into three smaller
problems and makes it trivially easy to
compute something like this without
getting any large results in between
which I think is a really really cool
who learned something new
fantastic
God created the integers the rest is the
work of man we are done with integers
what's next
floats okay
on Facebook I made a cute little post
before I came here I said I got invited
to Israel to teach seventh grade math
I'm going to teach people how to compute
a hypotenuse and how to add some numbers
and how to square them
of course it gets really interesting
when you try and do those things on a
modern electronical computer
and do it fast and do it accurately so
our goal is accuracy and for n equal to
our work's already done IEEE 754
guarantees you
that if you do these operations they are
all correctly rounded that means within
uh one half unit in the uh last place
you get those things for free they are
part of the firmament they're given to
you if you're just doing a binary
operation or one unary operation this is
fantastic hey like my little Tech going
on here isn't nice okay math looks
beautiful
there's now the little problem that
happens is when our inputs of the same
magnitude we add them up let's say I'm
using six decimal places here
our result has seven decimal places we
have to throw one away and there is a
small amount of error that's okay
because it is still correctly rounded
the problem becomes when we add more
than two numbers together these little
guys accumulate and possibly they
accumulate by uh quite a bit and we lose
all kinds of wonderful things we take
for granted like addition being
commutative so you can rearrange the
numbers and get a different answer which
is very embarrassing when it comes to
clients especially when you're using
machine learning algorithms to where if
you take the data and rearrange it
slightly the same data gives different
answers particularly uh
in
you know it was interesting one time in
engineering school they thought anytime
you get within one percent or a tenth of
a percent of a number it's good enough
you know run things out three decimal
places so why do we care about these
last bits of uh accuracy and the answer
is we're using these numbers as a
decision criteria in machine learning
when you're using K means you compute
the distances uh between points and if
something if two points are right at the
same distance if one of them has a
slight roundoff error it's either in the
set or out of the set depending on uh
the round off error so slight rounding
differences completely changes results
for K means for support Vector machines
and K nearest neighbors so these things
will matter to you at uh higher levels
so that was the little problem the
bigger problem happens when the inputs
have different magnitudes so this one is
shifted over a little bit from this one
now we have several extra digits that
are lost and a little bit larger error
again with two numbers this is no big
deal it's still correctly rounded you
start paneling these together they
accumulate and they accumulate uh fast
people like Tim Peters are really good
at coming up with pathological examples
that are off by hundreds of thousands of
percent uh just from adding up uh on
numbers
but if we can get rid of this error
we get commutativity back we get
guaranteed our results for our algorithm
so
how do you add up consecutive numbers
this is the way they taught us in school
start with a running total of zero take
your numbers add them on to the total
you all knew that right how to add
to add two and then you add a third one
then you add a 40. okay all right you've
got the uh just
so uh this is actually super interesting
to analyze mathematically and I I'm
going to give you a list little list of
articles that I just found fun to read
and one of them was in the Feynman
lectures on physics there was a lecture
on a probability that starts off with
this example
and then it computes the RMS error for
this this is a random lop and then uh
being a Feynman lecture on physics
they take all of the math and make it
immediately relevant to you and as soon
as they compute this they relate it to
the behavior of a gas and work up to uh
uh Boltzmann's Constant and the uh gas
laws
and how measurement errors work so an
error analysis of this is really at the
heart of what we do in probability and
statistics
going from here and adding up all the
little errors uh you know from the
central limit theorem that's what gives
us our normal curve of error and this is
why the normal curve of error has uh
this is the RMS difference it's variance
so this is our Baseline we will Define
it as as bad as it can get worst case
error every single step puts you one for
a step away from where you want to be do
you like lots of error
oh no you do not let's make it better an
easy way to minimize some of the loss of
precision is we realized we had a bigger
problem when the uh there was a
difference in magnitudes of the inputs
than when the inputs were closer
together
so a very simple solution that you can
do with any data set to make it better
if you'd like to improve the accuracy
before you add it you should sort it so
we sort the data by its absolute value
first so the smallest magnitudes all get
to interact with each other and if
they're all going the same direction
they get to contribute to the sum for
larger magnitudes otherwise their
contributions get washed away early on
this is the easiest thing you can do to
improve the accuracy of your sorting who
learned something new
oh fantastic
a better bit of Technology
is pairwise Edition you have this list
of numbers to add together we add them
in a tree we add these two together
these two these two and these two then
take the next group of two add those
together and the next group of two to
add them together this limits the amount
of error that can percolate up and it
does so in proportion to the logarithm
of the number of uh steps so we get
dramatically better uh error going from
square root of n to the square root of
the log of N
and that just takes massive amounts of
air and shrinks it down to uh
nothingness
what tool do you use that has this built
into it
starts with a num ends with a pie I'm
pointing at the answer
numpy every time you run sum this is
what it's doing it is not doing this up
here so here's the algorithm for it cut
the data set in half uh add the the two
halves and do that recursively working
your way down very easy to implement in
this tiny bit of code gets rid of most
of the air from square root of n to the
square root of the log of uh n who
learned something new
all right who's the biggest name in
numerical computing
Uncle Kahan Uncle Kahan uh
is the father of uh the IEEE 754 uh uh
floating Point standard on which
everything you do rest our modern world
that we can now reason about is
basically due to this fellow and he came
up with an idea we can improve our
accuracy even further by keeping two
running totals we can track the total
itself and then subtract from it the
total that we should have gotten keeping
a compensation or a second difference so
we have a main term an error term so we
just use two registers instead of one
and this is uh uh Kahan compensated
Edition and it does even better than
pairwise arithmetic numpy doesn't use it
because it's a little bit more expensive
to compute it doubles the amount of uh
memory
17 minutes good there's a variant of
that from on Niemeyer he said you know
there's a problem with this what if you
get a piece of data X that is bigger
than your running total then this
subtraction right here throws away your
accuracy in favor of uh the new term so
Neymar modified this and say I'm going
to compare the total to my latest term
and then decide which direction to
subtract and that got rid of the biggest
problem with K in addition which is once
in a while a large magnitude number
comes along swamps the computation and
throws away your accuracy and sir do you
like that
oh you don't have time to spare and you
don't have spare bits to throw around as
well I understand the other difference
from Acadian Edition is that the
correction factor gets applied only once
and at the end this will become
important to us later
but if you want to run this function now
it would give you even better accuracy
than kohim which is better than uh
pairwise which numpy uses which is way
better than just adding them all up who
learned something new
fantastic
but if two partials is good what would
be better than two partials
three what would be better than three
four as many as you need
okay and so somebody got this idea let's
do as many as we need I found this paper
many years ago I've given you a link to
it I'll give you all of these slides you
can click into it and essentially it
says let's have sorted non-overlapping
partial sums adding as many as we need
and so this little routine I think I
published about 15 years ago 17 now and
it improves the accuracy from
pretty close to perfect
who learned something new
and it was a popular algorithm so we
moved it into the standard Library what
is it known as today
fsum fsum gives you commutativity back
anytime you compare about accuracy who's
your new best friend
F sum there you go there's one other way
if you don't
oh you care about your time but you sir
clearly deny you have clock Cycles to
spare
and in pursuit of perfection you're
willing to throw away some clock Cycles
aren't you sir
I can see
that you would like to use fraction
module fraction modules is in pure
python it is not fast it's become faster
there's some interesting stories there
as well but we will leave those for
another day
convert your data into fractions and
then add them up and adding up fractions
is lossless is it fast
oh no it is not is it perfect
absolutely
so that's what the statistics module
does where it goes completely Gonzo
so the statistics module has an internal
function a sum
that accumulates as many partials as it
needs using an uh exact integer ratio
for its inputs whether they be decimal
or float
and it accumulates uh the total it
counts all of the inputs and it
remembers the input data type so we can
give you back the same type you put in
fractions go in fractions go out decimal
goes in decimal goes out float goes in
float goes out integers go in you might
or might not get integers out depending
on how that goes
you'll never have to write this function
it's an internal function in the
statistics module and it's used by
everything in the statistics module you
compute a mean in statistics it is
perfect every time it's commutative and
it will match exactly what you get if
you use the decimal module and run this
out a thousand places who thinks that's
awesome
the tricky one oh and you get the
variance and the population variance
this is fantastic but what about the
standard deviation what do you have to
do to convert variants into a standard
deviation
square root that's going to take us into
the float world isn't it
Mark Dickinson came up with this little
bit of magic it doesn't look like much
that tiny bit of code can take any
fractional ratio and uh turn it back
into an integer root and then convert to
a float losslessly correctly rounded
every time
I was dazzled and amazed like only this
little is involved well it turns out
somebody got a a PhD writing up uh
designing how this could be done
I'm just like the magic of round to odd
I'd never heard of such a thing when you
were converting from one level of
precision to another rounding to the
nearest odd turns out to be the correct
strategy so that a subsequent uh
rounding is guaranteed to avoid a double
rounding at a uh a split point so that
was Mark Dickinson's contribution which
means your standard deviations uh in the
statistics modules are perfect who likes
perfect
reproducible all kinds of goodness come
there it caused uh it cost you a little
bit of a speed that's all
okay
we are done with
addition oh here at the bottom I try all
of those and look at the answers that
they give in this particular example uh
the answers are all the same in fact I
have random inputs so if I rerun those
uh we'll get different sometimes these
will differ a little bit in the last
place and as we go down they get more
and more perfect
and finally the uh the statistics sum
tells you that it's a float gives you
the fractional rate ratio and the count
of the number of inputs uh that went in
all right
11 minutes this is the one you've been
waiting for the hypotenuse
multi-dimensional versus the Pythagorean
theorem
see cute little Tech at the top all
right
I love how well it draws math so I'm
going to do this one as a uh a numpy
example mostly so I'll start it out with
uh three numbers that I want to compute
the uh hypotenuse of
well you look at the formula what's the
first thing you should do with your
inputs that involves this little uh
superscript too
Square it that would be too easy what
happens immediately when you square
these components
they overflow what's the solution
scale the inputs
we've known that for a while and in the
Python 3 9 version of this the scaling
that I put in I divided by the largest
number but when you divide you introduce
one unit in last place uh error so it
actually created some error that wasn't
there before so should you just divide
by the largest number oh no you should
not what would uh
what type of division would be perfect
by a
power of two so that's what uh we do
here this is a scaling Factor you can
see in the hex representation of it
that's all zeros that tells you that
it's a power of two and it takes those
big numbers and makes them small of
course we'll need to unscale it uh when
we're done okay
now you need to square it what's the
problem with squaring
how many digits does it take to do an
exact Square
twice as many uh digits so at 53 digits
go into the square how many digits do
you get out
106. how many does a double hold only 53
where do the rest of them go usually
people throw them away that's terrible
do you like to throw away your extra
bits not when you care about accuracy so
if double Precision isn't good enough
what do we need
quad Precision so uh this technology has
been around since 1971 this is called
Camp Decker splitting I want to give you
a list of papers ones that I think are
actually enjoyable to read uh you can
see what people work this out a long
time ago we cut the numbers into two
half Precision numbers because what
happens when we Square them it takes how
many digits
twice as many so if you made it half as
big to begin with and you double the
number of digits you filled your space
up without overflowing so I'll take our
Vector multiply it by the belt Bank belt
Camp Decker constant and split it into
two groups high and low and let's take a
look at this
the high number when you put it out in
HEX do you notice that half of the
digits have become zeros
and for the low number half of the
digits have become zeros so they're now
each occupying half a bucket if you add
the two back together they come back up
to the original so we've lost nothing
but we've cut them into half size
buckets are you following so far are you
excited about that as much as I am
almost okay so now we need to multiply
them together our whole goal was to
square but this time it's in two parts
High plus low and you learn this uh in
your second week in algebra when you
square that you go from two terms to
three High squared two high low and low
squared
numpy makes short work of this doing all
of the components
you can see that uh this is large it's a
10th minus fifth this is medium minus
thirteenth and this is small the minus
21. keep in mind when we sum those three
back together they are exactly our
square and we have lost no bits so far
it is absolutely perfect do you like
perfect
you know I do this is fantastic so and I
uh verify here that in fact that is uh
uh that if we did collapse them right
now they're close to our uh Square now I
need to add all of these together can
you just use straight addition and throw
away all of your hard one bits know what
technique did you recently learn
compensated Edition on the previous uh
page in this example here to keep it
short I'm going to use f sum inside it
uses the uh numera summation and then I
modified the algorithm to add a bias to
it to make it fast so we could skip the
uh Branch inside and that gives us the
uh some of the squares
this is great and so far that sum of
squares is perfect until the output of
this function and this is the first time
we round
that's okay we wanted to correctly round
it up that'd be great if we were
stopping here but we're not what do we
have to do next to the number
and square root is uh correctly rounded
this is great so we're done
oh no we're not if you put a correctly
rounded input into a correctly rounding
function the output is not correctly
rounded
they don't stack together this actually
introduces uh an error of up to one unit
in the last place this is terrible do
you want errors in your computation sir
oh no you do not so we need to square it
uh fix the square root and the way to do
it is to unsquare it
compute the difference from our full
Precision with uh all of the bits that
we had before that were perfect
and then come up with a correction term
got a little McLaren series expansion of
here's the error term here's the
unsquaring
and so our correction is this difference
divided by 2H
so
I'll take uh split it back into its
components do perfect piecewise squaring
as we did before drop that back into our
F sum which is the exact arithmetic
there and we get that little difference
X and apply the correction it is now
perfect out to uh 106 bits we have quad
precision
pretty cool
is perfect
well I haven't been able to prove it's
always perfect so it's perfect out to
106 bits which is great undo the scaling
is that going to introduce error
it's a power of two is it going to
introduce error oh no it is not and
there is our perfect output and we
compare it with math hypot this of
course is all dog slow did you see all
those steps I did
it was crazy I think what can I do about
this oh use the magic of modern
processors you know the floating Point
Unit can do several computations in
parallel all I need to do is break up
the chain of data dependencies so I took
the accumulators for the fractional
Point uh portion and I put three
separate accumulators when I did here is
the new data flow of what goes in
there's our velcamp constant the scale
and we have a series of steps but the uh
the low fraction combines with one
number Loops back around and this is an
input the big box and this is an output
there's only two steps in between here
and here when you're doing this uh doing
a repeated number of steps likewise the
output of this one goes directly into
this one one step and this part loops
around and it's also one step so our
critical path is actually fairly short
let's measure it first of all I compute
High iPod on with three coordinates
takes 67 nanoseconds
with four coordinates
71.9 and 5 coordinates 76. the
difference for these is each extra
coordinate cost you four nanoseconds
for those of you aren't doing Nanos in
your head your processor is running mine
was running at the time 3.6 gigahertz
this is exactly 13 instructions per
additional uh piece of data and that
includes the decoding out of a python
boxed flow
who thinks it's kind of cool
and it's perfect
and it's fast
right and I don't have a dimension curse
it works perfectly well up I tested it
on Thousand dimensional inputs
it's great I'm very pleased with it and
the only people in the world who I could
tell about it who would understand was
you thank you so much I feel liberated
three minutes away
all right what of it
what's this useful for tweeting my son's
watching a video he's 10 years old he's
watching Bry the math guy who told him
told him about hypotenuse sequences you
know the three four five triangle
well interestingly if you have a 10 11
12 it matches the 1314 which is kind of
interesting
this is a nice little run 55 to 60
matches the hypotenuse of 61 to 65.
aren't this is kind of cool and
interesting
which raises the question can we find
more of these an obvious way to do this
is to take all combinations of the uh
low number the medium number and the
high and just test them all to see if
their hypotenuse is agree
and so I run this and it gives us lots
of interesting ranges solving this
problem making for a really nice tweet
hmm
here's the problem
if you ran this on numpy or on the
python 39 version of uh python it would
get the wrong answer it would skip some
of these little rounding errors are they
your friend when you're doing exact
equality test oh no they are not
this simple beautiful bit of code
gives the wrong answer but now it is
perfect all the way up to 2 to the 53.
you learn something new
do you like Perfection do you like being
able to write simple code and no it's
just going to work
fantastic all right hypot is used inside
the distance function in the math module
why do you care because the distance is
used in support Vector machines came
nearest neighbors uh and K means and an
accurate distance makes all the
difference between inclusion and
exclusion of a data point and with these
high level tools and just core python
writing uh K nearest neighbors boils
down to three lines of code that's dead
on accurate every time that's my story
and I'm sticking with it thank you for
inviting me
I don't know if I have time for
questions do I
no one said no I'll take them yes sir
oh 45 minutes on the button
first of all the problem becomes even
worse when you extend expanding things
when those things
explanations this is one of the problems
yes the curse of dimensionality as you
mentioned before so and higher
dimensional spaces everything gets hard
little problems become very uh big
problems uh in a
Square we have most of the area of a
square is near the edges
in our Cube it gets even closer to the
edge and in a multi uh as you go up
increasing Dimensions essentially all of
the points are always on the surface of
a uh hypersphere which means that these
little accuracy problems just go
my question is when people available on
what version
this one is in Python 310.
it's already there I snuck it in while
you weren't looking
[Music]
[Music]
the math module is the regular python
from my point of view no no I mean
one plus
[Music]
python at the core just as an
interpreted language it does the most
dirt simple possible thing there's very
little in the way of optimizations I put
a people Optimizer in a few years ago
and Cueto was very very clear just a
very very minimal changes that can't
have any observable effect uh and so I
can't do a reduction of strength of if
you multiply five numbers together I
can't turn it into an exponent
what this will have to use
right thank you that's exactly it yes
next
numpy
[Music]
so the numpy sum got pairwise Edition I
think like six or seven years ago it was
a
you know for me it feels recent but I've
been in Python world for a long time so
it is already in what you're using
almost certainly uh
the if you need the dead on accuracy the
formulas I put here I actually did a
numpy example so you can just cut and
paste my code and uh and get that if
needed that said there you know there's
always a balance when it comes to a
speed and so it will cost you a few
clock Cycles unless you just go
implement it from scratch and see as I
did that's it you can always just take
map uh map and apply the math iPod to
the numpy functions and the only cost
you're going to pay is the cost of
boxing the number out of numpy running
through hypot and boxing uh back which
is not a huge overhead you know it's
it's not as fast as doing it straight in
numpy but it doesn't differ by much so
yeah you can definitely use this in the
numpy world
foreign
okay way better than that picture did
you all see the picture they introduced
me with
the least flattering picture of me that
was ever taken but it was kind of a nice
quote though okay
uh any other questions suggestions
comments or complaints
all right you've seen the technology of
the uh interstack the stuff that you're
building on top of the rest of the day
people are going to show you what they
do with that stack all the high level
applications that are made I can't wait
to see the rest of your talks thank you
so much
thank you
[Music]